.
IT'S A SPECIAL MONDAY.
>> IT'S A GREAT MONDAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THE HIGH STAKES MID-TERMS
ELECTIONS 8 DAYS AWAY.
IT APPEARS PRESIDENT BIDEN IS ON
THE SIDELINES OR IN DELAWARE.
EVEN SOME OF THE CANDIDATES IN
BLUE STATES ARE LOCKED IN TIGHT
RACES.
CONTROL FROM THE SENATE COULD
COME DOWN TO A FEW KEY MATCH
UPS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THE
MID-TERM ELECTIONS ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT IN OUR LIFETIME, HE
SPENT THE WEEKEND AT HOME IN
DELAWARE.
HE DID GO OUT TO DO EARLY VOTING
ON SATURDAY.
THERE IS ARE NO COMPETITIVE
CONGRESSIONAL RACES THIS CYCLE.
HIS FORMER BOSS BARACK OBAMA IS
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL AND MAKING
COMMERCIALS AND CAME OUT
SWINGING AT THE GOP.
>> I HAVE TO SPEAK THE TRUTH,
WHICH IS THESE DAYS JUST ABOUT
EVERY REPUBLICAN POLITICIAN
SEEMS OBSESSED WITH 2 THINGS:
LET'S OWN THE LIBS.
AND GETTING DONALD TRUMP'S
APPROVAL.
THAT'S THEIR AGENDA.
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
SOLVING PROBLEMS.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN MAKING
YOU ANGRY AND FINDING SOMEBODY
TO BLAME.
THEY ARE HOPING THAT WILL
DISTRACT YOU FROM THE FACT THEY
DON'T HAVE ANSWERS OF THEIR OWN.
YOUR VOTE WILL MAKE
A DIFFERENCE.
THAT'S WHY REPUBLICANS ARE
WORKING SO HARD TO STOP YOU.
>> HMMM.
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE
CHAIR ONE OF THOSE REPUBLICANS
TOLD ME ON THE "FOCUS" HOPING
OBAMA CAN SALVAGE THINGS LOOKS
LIKE DESPERATION.
>> IT'S EVIDENT THEY ARE NOT
PUTTING BIDEN ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
THE CANDIDATES DON'T WANT TO BE
WITH BIDEN.
HIS APPROVAL RATING IS RECORD
LOW.
TIM RYAN AND WARNOCK DON'T WANT
TO BE SEEN WITH HIM.
NOBODY WANTS BIDEN IN THEIR
STATE.
HE IS STUCK IN DELAWARE.
THEY ARE PULLING OUT THE RELIC
OF OBAMA AND HOPE THAT LIFTS
THEIR CHANCES.
>> ONE STATE THAT COULD USE
HELP.
THE NUMBERS FOR STACEY ABRAMS.
SHE IS GETTING FARTHER AWAY FROM
KEMP.
>> AS MUCH AS SHE CAN.
IT'S FALLING AWAY.
THE COATTAILS FOR OBAMA IN
GEORGIA ARE NOT THAT LONG.
THEY HAVE NOTHING ELSE.
BIDEN WON'T HELP ANYBODY IN
GEORGIA OR ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ABRAMS WHO WAS A POLISHED AND
FOCUSSED POLITICIAN LOST IT
RECENTLY.
SHE WILL GET BEAT.
THERE IS NOTHING DEMOCRATS CAN
DO TO HELP HER.
>> YOU HEARD RONNA, THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE NEAR HIM.
THERE ARE A LOT OF POLICY
REASONS THAT MAY BE TRUE, BUT
THIS IS NOT HELPING.
BIDEN CLAIMED THERE WERE HOW
MANY STATES?
LET'S WATCH.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> STILL DETERMINED TO ELIMINATE
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
THAT'S WHY THEY WERE DEFEATED IN
2018 AND WE WENT TO 54 STATES.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> BACK TO THE FUTURE.
MAYBE WE WILL GO TO 54.
THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT BECAUSE
IT'S SO DIRE FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, THEY SEE HE IS THE
LARGEST LIABILITY.
THERE IS NOT WIGGLE ROOM ANYMORE
TO LET THIS PRESIDENT HAVE THOSE
GAFFES AND FOR VOTERS TO LAUGH
IT OFF.
THERE IS NOTHING LAUGHABLEAR SKY
ROCKET IN
ING CRIME A
POLICE AND PEOPLE HAVE TO MAKE
A CHOICE BETWEEN HEATING THEIR
HOMES OR PAYING FOR GROCERY
BILLS.
OBAMA SUFFERED THE WORST MID
TERM SHELLACING IN 2010.
THE REALITY IS THE DEMOCRATS
WON'T TURNOUT.
ALL DAY LONG WE ARE WORKING TO
PUT FOOD ON OUR TABLE AND
EDUCATE OUR KIDS AND SECURE THE
BORDER.
WE ARE SEEING ALL OF THOSE
STRIPPED AWAY.
IT'S NOT US WORKING HARD TO
PREVENT THE DEMOCRATS FROM
SUCCEEDING.
THEY NEVER WORKED ON BEHALF OF
US.
>> I DON'T THINK FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA IS THAT
EFFECTIVE OF A CAMPAIGNER.
HE IS OUTDATED.
WHAT WAS ATTRACTIVE WITH HIM IN
2008, WE ARE IN SUCH DIFFERENT
LANDSCAPES NOW.
HE SEEMS OUT OF HIS DEPTH.
HE WAS ON STAGE ATTACKING THE
STRAW BAND.
WHERE IS THE TIN MAN?
[IMITATING HIS SPEECH].
>> YOU SAW HIM GET HECKLED.
>> THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT
CUTTING TAXES AND SPENDING IF
THEY ARE SMART.
IT'S NOT HARD TO COME UP WITH
A PLAN OPPOSITE OF WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
THEY OVERSPENT AND FLOODED THE
ECONOMY WITH TOO MUCH MONEY AND
DEVALUED THE DOLLAR IN THE
PROCESS.
WE HAVE SKY HIGH INFLATION.
THE SOLUTIONS THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
TALKING ABOUT IS JUST THROWING
MORE MONEY AT PROBLEMS INCLUDING
STUDENT LOAN DEBT RELIEF.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HEARD
MARIE HARPE WAS ON LAST HOUR.
SHE LISTED WHAT YOU LISTED AS
GOOD THINGS.
KENNEDY SAYS THEY ARE NOT GOOD
THINGS.
>> UNLESS YOU ARE ONE OF THE 66%
OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO
DON'T HAVE A COLLEGE DEGREE.
YOU ARE ON THE HOOK FOR PAYING
FOR PEOPLE WHO MADE CHOICES.
THAT IS NOT A GOOD THING.
IF IT WERE A GREAT PLAN,
CONGRESS WOULD HAVE PASSED IT.
>> THERE YOU GO.
TALK ABOUT BEING THAT VOICE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE NOW FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> INTERESTING.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE BEING
KARINE-JEAN PIERRE?
>> YES, I CAN'T.
OVER THE WEEKEND I ASKED OUR
TEAM TO PUT THIS TOGETHER.
I SAW KARINE-JEAN PIERRE MAKE
A COMMENT HAVING TO DEFEND WHY
HER BOSS IS NOT THE HEAD OF THE
PARTY OUT THERE CAMPAIGNING FOR
THE PARTY AND WHY IT'S PRESIDENT
OBAMA.
SHE IS CURRENTLY IN OFFICE AND
HAS TO SAY BIDEN'S TALKING
POINTS.
IT MADE ME THINK OF JEN PSAKI
THE PRIOR PRESS SECRETARY AM
A TALE OF TWO PRESS SECRETARIES.
>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT MAKING
THIS CASE AND NOT THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT?
>> I WOULD DISAGREE WITH THAT
CHARACTERIZATION OF YOUR
QUESTION.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS ALMOST EVERY DAY FOR
MONTHS NOW.
HE'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
CHOICES THAT ARE AT STAKE HERE.
>> DEMOCRATS IF THE ELECTION IS
ABOUT WHO IS THE MOST EXTREME,
THEY WILL WIN.
IF IT'S A REFERENDUM ON THE
PRESIDENT THEY WILL LOSE AND
THEY KNOW THAT.
>> IF IT WAS A JOB REEL JEN
PSAKI WOULD GET YEAR JOB BACK.
>> JEN PSAKI WAS HONEST THERE.
BIDEN IS NOT GOING TO ARIZONA OR
NEVADA BUT THE WAY HE IS USED.
HIS DESCRIPTION OF HIS FLORIDA
EVENTS.
HE IS GOING TO A FUNDRAISER AND
DOING AN EVENT ABOUT SOCIAL
SECURITY.
YOU HAVE A SCRIPTED ANSWER FROM
KARINE-JEAN PIERRE AND THE
HONEST ONE FROM JEN PSAKI.
THAT TELLS ME YOU HAVE A BAD
BOSS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
MY BOSS WENT TO 26 STATES.
HE WAS SOUGHT AFTER.
SO IS BARACK OBAMA IN 20 STATES.
>> THE LAST TIME BARACK OBAMA
WAS ON THE BALLOT WAS 10 YEARS
AGO.
>> HE'S THE BEST THEY'VE GOT.
I SAID TO MY HUSBAND IF I HAD TO
PICK ONE DEMOCRAT IT WOULD BE
BARACK OBAMA, BUT MAYBE NOT EVEN
HIM.
HE IS LIKEABLE.
IT'S ALL THEY'VE GOT.
>> THEY DON'T TROT HILLARY.
>> SHE IS COMING TO NEW YORK.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> GET THE FIREWORKS.
>> THE TEARS WILL START FLOWING
AND BROOKLYN CAN'T STAND THAT
ANYMORE.
IF THIS IS THE BEST THEY'VE GOT
IT REFLECTS BADLY ON BIDEN'S
DECISION AFTER THIS ELECTION ON
WHAT HAPPENS IN 2024.
FOR THOSE WHO LOOK AT BARACK
OBAMA, YES, HE IS OUTDATED BUT
HE'S THE BEST THEY'VE GOT.
HIS MESSAGE AND SMOOTH DEMEANOR
COMPARED TO SOMEONE WHO IS IN
THE BASEMENT OR A WALKING GAFFES
MONITOR.
I THINK THIS IS MORE LIKE ALICE
IN WONDERLAND.
WHAT IS UP IS DOWN A